sur le site archéologique de bibracte
difficile de différencier les touristes
des militants socialistes
cette année l'ascension prend des airs
de traversée du désert à ses fidèles qui
sont là a quand même mieux que ans n'est
plus seulement une trentaine de
militants du jamais vu et surtout un
grand absent c'est surtout arnaud
montebourg qui fait venir des gens et
pour ça d'habitude la foule a passé une
meute de journalistes c'est la bagarre
c'est du rugby y est là ah bah là bas
c'est un seul guide
il ya eu les beautés du bus vrai grand
cru des petits crus ben voilà on est il
ya des hauts des bas cette année on est
dans un creux mais comme la toul où tout
le ps a depuis quelques temps on va
gauche sur cette terre de résistance qui
est le morvan le parti socialiste
cherche une nouvelle direction
un nouveau souffle alors continuité dans
le rassemblement on continue à essayer
de de fédérer les forces socialistes on
voit bien que cette année c'est plus dur
dans une période où un peu aride
malgré la verdure qui nous entoure on
manque un peu d'eau ce que la gauche
cherche aussi c'est quelqu'un à suivre
tête d'affiché de cette édition emmanuel
maurel candidat à la présidence du ps
qui rappelle ici l'adn du parti le mont
beuvray c'est symbolique symbolique d'un
esprit de résistance et en même temps
d'une volonté de combattre en commun
franchement au parti socialiste c'est ce
qu'on devrait incarner je ne dis pas
qu'on la carte beaucoup mais en tout cas
c'est ça qu'on devrait faire pour le ps
le plus dur reste à faire bâtir un
projet pour redonner la maison